* Hupen *
* Fliessender Indie-Rock-Song *
# Don't look at me like this,
hun, don't be upset.
# What a wonderful day.
# Don't be mad at me
because I feel alright.
# I can't be happy
if you're not alright.
# Don't worry
cause I really feel alright.
# I go to the USA.
# We won't say goodbye, my buddy,
so let's move our bodies, buddy.
Das Leben für einen Architekten in
L.A. ist ein einziger Hindernislauf.
Vor den täglichen Scherereien
geht Roger in sein Lieblingscafe.
Ich komme her,
um meine E-Mails zu kontrollieren,
bevor ich
den ganzen Tag unterwegs bin.
Ich beantworte alle E-Mails,
die über Nacht reinkommen,
erledige das alles.
Wenn der Kaffee fertig ist,
sind meine E-Mails erledigt.
Dann kann ich gehen
und do my business.
Das ist mein drittes Büro.
Am Lenkrad seines rollenden zweiten
Büros flitzt er Richtung Malibu,
wo er versuchen wird,
die schwierige Situation
eines Kundenpaars zu entwirren,
das sich mit administrativem Kram
rumschlägt.
Wie geht's?
- Gut. Wie läuft's?
Ging es heute in der City?
Teilerfolg.
- Teilerfolg!
Hey, Esther.
- Schön, dass du hier bist.
How are you?
- Gut.
Sie haben
mit dem Ingenieur gesprochen.
Er hätte den Stempel draufgedrückt.
Am Schluss geht es nur ums Geld.
Dort 300 $, da 400 $.
Ich verstehe es nicht ganz,
denn es war richtig.
Vier Jahre hat es gedauert,
eine Baubewilligung zu bekommen.
Jetzt kann Roger sein Schweizer
Know-how unter Beweis stellen.
Man hat gemerkt,
dass Amerikaner z.T.
ganz anders ticken als Schweizer.
Oder sagen wir mal
die europäische Bauweise.
Die ist hier
noch nicht so verbreitet.
Das hat mich sehr erstaunt.
In Kalifornien ist ja sonst
eigentlich alles Hightech.
Diese Farbe ist ganz schön.
Die expectations meines
Schweizer Kunden sind ganz anders
als die expectations
eines Amerikaners.
In dieser Hinsicht
verstehen wir uns einfach besser,
deshalb funktioniert es.
Ich sage nichts.
- Sonst musst du sie schwarz machen.
Dann müsste der Rest auch so sein
und das will ich nicht.
Es gibt immer noch diese notion,
dass der Schweizer ...
Er ist immer pünktlich,
er macht seine Sache,
wenn er sagt, es sei bis Freitag
fertig, ist es bis Freitag fertig.
Das ist in Amerika nicht immer so.
Ja, ja, das gibt es immer.
Wir sind hierhergekommen
und haben - böse gesagt -
die Immobilienkrise ausgenutzt.
Wir haben Häuser gekauft.
Wir haben sie renoviert
und vermieten sie.
Und dann haben wir bald gemerkt:
Die Bauweise und das Ganze hier
ist ein Vorteil,
wenn man neu bauen will.
Also haben wir entschieden,
ein Stück Land zu kaufen,
ein Haus darauf zu bauen
und dieses zu verkaufen.
Fast hätten sie bei den Waldbränden
alles verloren.
Man hat es draussen gesehen,
das Feuer ist auf 10 m
an das Haus herangekommen.
Alles davor und dahinter steht noch.
Alles links und rechts
ist abgebrannt.
Während dieser zehn Tage
wussten wir nicht,
ob unser Haus auch betroffen ist.
Sie haben niemanden mehr
in das Gebiet reingelassen.
Wenn so etwas passiert,
ist es natürlich sehr emotional.
Das gibt die eine oder andere
schlaflose Nacht.
* Einsame Westerngitarre *
Unglaublich, wie grün es schon ist.
Wir fahren zum Kanan Drive,
um die Ruinen der Brände
vom November zu sehen.
Man riecht es noch, das Feuer.
Riechst du es?
Schau, es ist dunkelbraun.
Es ist entscheidend,
ob sich die Windböen
nach links oder nach rechts bewegen.
Entweder weht der Wind
in deine Richtung oder nicht -
es ist total willkürlich.
Das ist echt hart.
(Computerstimme) In half a mile turn
left onto Paramount Ranch Drive.
Hier kommen ein paar kräftige Waden.
Kanan,
45 Min. von der Stadt entfernt,
eine Filmstadt, vom Feuer zerstört.
Das waren alles alte Filmkulissen.
Diese Kirche wurde, glaube ich, für
die TV-Serie "Westworld" verwendet.
Danach wurde auch der Rest dieses
Anwesens für "Westworld" genutzt.
Ich glaube, die ersten Brände
habe ich 2005 gesehen,
damals brannte Griffith Park.
Man sah die Flammen von
zu Hause aus, v.a. aber den Rauch.
Diese enormen Rauchmassen,
die auf die Stadt zukommen.
Ich frage mich,
wie man das darstellen kann.
Die Panik, die um sich greift,
wenn man nichts tun kann.
Und auch all diese
verlassenen städtischen Gebiete.
All die abgebrannten Orte, wo sich
Natur und Architektur vermischen,
wo Eisenteile und Baumstämme
zusammenwachsen.
Man kann sie nicht mehr
voneinander unterscheiden.
Ich versuche, so viel Material
wie möglich zusammenzubekommen,
so viele Fotos wie möglich
zu machen.
Ich gehe herum und fotografiere.
Nach Ereignissen
wie z.B. einem Brand
kehre ich also
an diese abgebrannten Orte zurück.
Das ist wie verbrannte Erde.
Verkohlt und nass. Es ist bizarr.
* Fliessende elektronische Musik *
Aus der Asche wiedergeboren werden.
Hier ergibt das Sinn.
Tausende Hektar Land zerstört.
Hunderte von Toten.
In Los Angeles mutieren Träume
schnell zu Albträumen.
Feuer, Dürre, Erdbeben -
das Leben führt
einen teuren Kampf gegen den Tod.
Doch die Stadt gewinnt letztlich
doch immer die Oberhand zurück.
Das ist eben Los Angeles.
Für Lauriane rast die Zeit.
Schon nach wenigen Wochen
stehen die ersten Prüfungen an.
Ich muss unbedingt lernen.
Die sog. Midterms stehen an.
Das ist eine Prüfung,
die Mitte des Jahres stattfindet
und 40 % der Note ausmacht.
Man muss also etwas weniger lernen,
weil es ja nur fünf Wochen Arbeit
sind, aber trotzdem.
Toll finde ich hier,
dass die Bibliothek
24 Std. durchgehend geöffnet hat.
So ist man flexibel.
Ich kann mich in der Nacht
viel besser konzentrieren.
Am Morgen lernen
ist nicht mein Ding.
Wenn ich bis 4 Uhr in der Früh
in der Bibliothek lernen
und am nächsten Tag bis 14 Uhr
schlafen will, kann ich das tun.
Ich kann das selbst entscheiden.
Ein echter Pluspunkt für mich.
* Handy *
Salut.
- Geht's gut?
Ja, gut.
Wie läuft es?
- Es geht.
Es ist kalt und ich habe den ganzen
Januar für meine Prüfungen gelernt.
Okay, so ein Pech.
Ich hatte auch keine Ferien.
Das ist doch fast wie Ferien,
was du dort hast.
Nein, ich muss büffeln.
Na gut, danke dir.
Wir hören uns bald wieder.
Bisous!
Ich versuche immer,
meine Mutter zu beruhigen.
Wenn mich plötzlich
etwas stressen sollte,
werde ich jemand anderen
als meine Mutter anrufen,
um sie nicht zu beunruhigen.
* Einsame Westerngitarre *
Dora bereitet die Rückkehr
in die Schweiz vor.
Ihre Bilder nimmt sie nicht mit.
Diese Gemälde sind Originale.
Sie stammen
aus der Galerie meines Grossvaters.
Er hat in der Stadt Zürich
eine der ersten Galerien eröffnet.
Mein Grossvater
und später dann seine Söhne
haben diese Galerie
sehr lange geführt.
Die Bilder habe ich geerbt,
als mein Vater gestorben ist.
Aber ich bin
mit diesen Bildern aufgewachsen,
sie sind schon seit Ewigkeiten
in der Familie.
Ich habe sie
nach New York mitgenommen.
Und später dann nach Los Angeles.
Und jetzt ist es Zeit,
mit weniger auszukommen.
Mit wenig auskommen,
das kennt Randy gut.
Roger!
* Lockrufe *
Jede Katze hat ihre Persönlichkeit.
Ich kann mich gut
mit Roger identifizieren,
weil er gross und freundlich ist.
Er ist immer der Erste, der mich
begrüsst, wenn ich sie füttere.
Und die anderen
kommen dann hinterher.
Ich bin selbst kein Mitläufer,
ich bin immer
meinen eigenen Weg gegangen.
Ich tue, was ich für richtig halte.
Ich habe bewusst
nie eine Familie gegründet,
dafür haben mir die Tiere
immer Geborgenheit gegeben.
Sie helfen mir, mich zu entspannen.
Man könnte sagen,
sie sind meine Kinder.
Vor einem Jahr habe ich mir
ein Haus in der Wüste gekauft.
Diesen Wohnwagen benutze ich,
wenn ich in Los Angeles arbeite
und nicht nach Hause fahren will,
weil mein Haus fast zwei Autostunden
entfernt ist.
Weil ich während neun Jahren
in diesem Gebäude gewohnt habe,
geben meine ehemaligen Nachbarn
auf den Wohnwagen acht
und kümmern sich um die Katzen.
Hallo Emilyn, wir sind da
und haben die Bilder dabei.
Wir nehmen sie.
Nein, lass nur!
Doras Kollegin Emilyn war sofort
an den Bildern interessiert.
Europäische Malerei gilt
bei Amerikanern als sicherer Wert.
Ich stelle es hierhin,
weil ich denke,
dass hier oben der beste Platz ist.
Jetzt, wo meine Bilder hier sind,
muss ich hier einziehen.
Wir haben ein freies Zimmer.
Die Kinder sind weg.
Kannst du gut Bilder aufhängen?
- Ja.
Wir stellen es zuerst
auf den Kaminsims,
dann kannst du es hochheben.
Dann siehst du, wo es sein muss.
Are we okay?
- Okay.
Es ist gerade, oder?
- Ich glaube, ja.
Es ist ein Abschied, ja.
Ich liebe diese Bilder,
v.a. dieses hier.
Wir werden gut auf sie achten,
keine Sorge.
Ich werde dir Fotos schicken.
Es ist gut, zu sehen,
dass sie einen wirklich schönen
Platz bekommen haben.
Wir lieben diese Bilder, und
diese Bucht ist einfach grossartig.
Das ist mein Lieblingsbild,
und das von Louis Charlot.
Wir werden sie immer in Ehren halten
und sie
an unsere Kinder weitergeben.
Danke, das bedeutet mir sehr viel.
Du kannst sie jederzeit besuchen.
Sie waren etwa 100 Jahre
im Besitz der Familie.
Geschafft.
So habe ich sie immer noch.
* Einsame Westerngitarre *
Hier wird nicht zwangsläufig
innerhalb der Familie vererbt.
Man kann auch
unter Freunden vererben.
Mein Wohnwagen
ist ein Geschenk eines Kunden,
der letztes Jahr verstorben ist.
Er hatte ihn
für sich selbst gekauft,
und als er ihn nicht mehr brauchte,
hat er ihn mir geschenkt.
Er war Schauspieler
und hat im Film "Full Metal Jacket"
den Marine Sergeant gespielt -
Lee Ermey.
Er sagte zu mir: "Nimm das Wohnmobil
und lebe dein Abenteuer!"
Wenn ich irgendwo hingehe, muss ich
nur Essen und Eiswürfel kaufen.
Ansonsten habe ich praktisch alles.
Es ist wichtig, immer
einen Sonnenschirm dabeizuhaben.
Hier habe ich Flossen
und das hier ist ein Schwimmbrett.
Ein Golfschläger.
Dann ein Mikrowellenherd.
Und das ist der Kühlschrank,
der leer ist,
weil ich ihn nicht benutze.
Den Kochherd
habe ich noch nicht benutzt,
weil ich noch nie
richtig gekocht habe.
Jede Katze hat ihre Vorlieben,
genau wie wir Menschen.
Ich esse z.B. kein Fleisch.
Ich bin Vegetarier,
aber nicht zu 100 % Veganer,
weil ich als Schweizer immer noch
gerne ab und zu Käse esse.
Ich lebe seit zehn Jahren so
und fühle mich heute viel besser.
* Hüpfende Popmusik *
Lauriane will die Stadt erobern.
Endlich taucht sie
aus ihrer Bücherwelt auf.
Wir sind auf dem Weg ins Stadt-
zentrum, nach Downtown Los Angeles.
Wir werden uns das Künstlerviertel
ansehen, den Arts District.
Es ist schön, die Sonne scheint,
und es macht Spass, die Stadt
bei solchem Wetter zu besichtigen.
Allerdings ist es schon
eine Autostadt.
Man hört das ja die ganze Zeit,
aber wenn man hier ankommt, hat man
wirklich sofort diesen Eindruck.
Man sieht selten
Menschen zu Fuss unterwegs,
ausser sie gehen
mit ihrem Hund Gassi.
Ansonsten nimmt man das Auto.
Da mir der Umweltschutz wichtig ist,
ist es schon gewöhnungsbedürftig.
* Schleppende, elektronische Musik *
45 Min. von Hollywood entfernt locken
die Reize des Ozeans in San Pedro.
Überall Jachten, Boot an Boot,
so weit das Auge reicht.
Um den unzähligen alltäglichen
Herausforderungen zu entkommen,
sticht Roger gerne in See.
Okay.
I'm already sweating.
Als ich etwa acht Jahre alt war,
lernte ich auf dem Walensee segeln.
Ich habe den Segelschein gemacht,
auf dem Walensee
und auf dem Mittelmeer.
Dann bin ich hergezogen und habe
mit Regattasegeln angefangen,
auf verschiedenen Booten.
Es ist ein guter Ausgleich zum
Alltagsleben von Montag bis Freitag.
Es ist einfach schön,
draussen zu sein.
Es hilft,
den ganzen Stress abzubauen.
So ist man am Montag wieder frisch.
Dann kann man wieder Vollgas geben.
* Treibende Musik *
In L.A. ist Sport Religion -
Glaubenssache und Halt.
Sport hat hier weit mehr Anhänger
als die Kirchen.
Für einen langen Aufstieg
braucht man bequeme Schuhe.
Wasser, wir brauchen viel Wasser,
weil es
ein ganz schönes Stück Weg ist.
Die Schlüssel, natürlich mit Schwei-
zerkreuz auf dem Schlüsselband.
Bis gleich.
Geht es?
- Ja, danke.
Alles in Ordnung?
Ja, wenn Sie mich zur Tür
begleiten könnten, zu diesem Haus.
Randy besteigt
seine stattlichen Pferdestärken
und macht sich auf in die Berge.
Wenn man in die Berge geht,
muss man sich vor Klapperschlangen
und Pumas in Acht nehmen.
Wenn du auf die Hügel gehst,
sollst du dich
vor wilden Tieren in Acht nehmen.
Hello.
- Hello. Come back, it's a warm day.
Unter den hungrigen Augen
der Kojoten, Schlangen und Pumas
erklimmt Randy mit strammem Schritt
die steilen Pfade
der Hollywood Hills.
Das da drüben,
das ist der künstliche See.
Er heisst Lake Hollywood und ist
ein künstlicher Trinkwasser-Stausee.
Los Angeles ist eine schöne Stadt,
und wenn man jung ist,
hat sie einem viel zu bieten.
Deshalb sollte man so früh
wie möglich hierherkommen -
so mit 18, 19 oder 20 Jahren.
Ich war 25 Jahre alt,
als ich hierherkam.
Ich wäre gerne früher gekommen,
aber ich hatte damals
eine Arbeit und eine Freundin.
Deshalb habe ich
etwas länger gewartet.
Wenn man älter wird,
wenn man in Rente geht,
gehen viele Leute
zurück in die Schweiz.
Da ist es viel ruhiger, das Leben
in der Schweiz ist entspannter.
Los Angeles
ist das genaue Gegenteil.
Hier heisst es:
"Los, los, los, mach, mach, mach!"
Darum empfehle ich jungen Leuten,
nicht zu zögern.
Dafür muss man halt sein Zuhause
zurücklassen, was nicht einfach ist.
Ich habe meine Arbeit, meine Familie
und meine Freunde verlassen,
aber es ist mein Leben und
ich wollte dieses Abenteuer leben.
Ich würde mich heute
wieder so entscheiden.
* Einsame Westerngitarre *
Lauriane erkundet derweil
einen anderen Dschungel.
Die Street Art -
wie ein Museum unter freiem Himmel.
Das Nirwana für jede Bildjägerin.
* Treibende Musik *
Jedes Jahr
kommen Hunderte Künstler nach L.A.
Wie früher die Goldwäscher
jagen sie alle
dem grossen Traum hinterher,
und nur einige unter ihnen
erlangen Berühmtheit
und bleiben so der Ewigkeit erhalten.
So wie Francescas Schwiegervater.
Oh, tut mir leid,
ich wollte nicht in eurem Bild sein.
Macht ihr auch Filmaufnahmen?
Ja, wir drehen einen Dokumentarfilm
fürs Schweizer Fernsehen.
Fürs Schweizer Fernsehen, echt?
Ich bin selber auch Schweizer,
was für ein Zufall.
Aus der Deutschschweiz?
- Ja, aus Schwyz.
Und ich habe
einen amerikanischen Pass.
Arbeitest du?
- Ich arbeite als Koch.
Weisst du, Schweizer Köche
sind überall bekannt.
Wir sind die Besten.
Das ist das erste Mal, dass ich hier
einem Schweizer über den Weg laufe.
Das geht mir auch so. Verrückt!
Schönen Tag noch.
Dir auch. Tschüss.
Ursprünglich hiess Los Angeles
"Das Dorf der Königin der Engel".
Wer ist heute
die kleine Königin der Engel?
Da drüben sind
die Studios von Warner Brothers
und da sind die Disney-Studios.
Wir sind also mitten im Zentrum
der Film- und Fernsehindustrie.
Der Burbank Airport,
wo mein Wohnwagen steht,
ist noch etwas weiter weg.
Ich wohne neben dem Flughafen.
Wahrzeichen haben manchmal
eine seltsame Entstehungsgeschichte.
Die Buchstaben des Hollywood-
Schriftzugs wurden 1923 errichtet,
um für das Immobilienprojekt
Hollywoodland zu werben.
25 Jahre später
liess die Handelskammer
den Schriftteil "Land" entfernen.
So entstand daraus
das Sinnbild des Hollywood-Kinos.
Wir sind da!
Beim Hollywood-Zeichen,
dem bekannten Schriftzug.
Weil es so viele Vandalenakte gab,
ist der Schriftzug nun
mit Absperrungen geschützt
und man gelangt nicht mehr
bis ganz zu den Buchstaben.
Ansonsten
zahlt man 1'000 $ Bussgeld.
* Einsame Westerngitarre *
Francesca bereitet ihre Ausstellung
für die Galerie in Zuoz vor,
die ihre Werke zum Thema
Feuer und Brände zeigen wird.
An ihrer Seite Maya,
ihre unentbehrliche Assistentin.
Versuch es mal mit diesen Rottönen!
Sollen wir das testen?
- Ja, bring ein paar rüber!
Das hier, dieses Weinrot.
Ich glaube ...
Wo ist das Farbenbuch?
Ich werde solche Rottöne verwenden.
So was in der Art.
Zuerst gebe ich ihr etwas zu tun,
dann arbeite ich
an etwas anderem weiter.
Ich werde schauen, ob ich
eine meiner kleinen Probearbeiten
vervielfältigen und danach
Ausschneidebilder machen kann.
Viele Leute haben mir gesagt,
es sei eine Schweizer Tradition,
Scherenschnitte zu machen.
Ich habe hier damit begonnen,
Scherenschnitte anzufertigen.
Ich habe
ein Wolkentagebuch angelegt,
das ist ähnlich wie beim Rauch,
die Formen ähneln sich.
I'll show a little bit
where we're at.
Es ist sehr heikel.
Ich arbeite seit vielen Jahren
in Francescas Atelier.
Davor habe ich sie
schon lange bewundert.
Da wir ja seit Langem
zusammenarbeiten,
tauschen wir Gedanken und Ideen aus.
Manchmal müssen wir sie
etwas konkretisieren,
weil die Ideen nur so sprudeln
und sie immer so viele Einfälle
und Pläne für die Zukunft hat,
dass ich manchmal Mühe habe
zu folgen.
Oh my god, check it out!
Schau dir die Wolken an!
Sie sehen aus wie Rauch.
* Einsame Westerngitarre *
Das ist noch kein Ausziehen,
sondern ein Umräumen.
Der Hausverkauf
hat auch seinen Preis.
Können wir das hier
etwas schrägstellen?
Diese Kabel müssen hier weg.
Ja, sie werden Fotos machen.
Sie machen Fotos
für das advertising des Hauses.
Wir müssen alles herrichten.
Das ist nur für das staging.
Für die Fotos.
* Drollige Musik *
It's too big for there.
It's better in there.
In den Vereinigten Staaten
werden Häuser umgestylt,
um die Verkaufschancen zu steigern.
Das Home Staging empfiehlt auch
eine Verschönerung der Deko.
Die Geschmäcker sind verschieden.
Wie geht's?
Kannst du mir diese grosse Wolke
leihen? Brauchst du sie gerade?
Die Brände
bezeichne ich als Spektakel.
Sie stehen für Zerstörung,
aber auch für Neuanfang.
Sie sind nicht nur negativ. Zumin-
dest versuche ich, das so zu sehen.
Ein Konfitüreglas mit Wasser.
Ich werde einen Wash machen,
und sobald es trocken ist,
werde ich einen Teil dazu verwenden,
die Rauchschwaden darzustellen,
die aus den Wolken hervorgehen.
Das hier ist mein Malerkittel.
Ich kann so viele Flecken
darauf machen, wie ich will.
Wie die Tropfen,
so entstehen auch die Flammen
recht spontan
auf dem farbigen Papier.
Pannen sind super, weil dabei
immer etwas Neues entsteht.
Über diese Dinge
habe ich nicht die volle Kontrolle.
Pasqual,
wir müssen über den Preis reden.
Mein Mindestpreis liegt bei 550.
Wenn wir das erreichen wollen,
brauchen wir eine Strategie.
Wenn wir bei 490 starten,
können wir bis 550 gehen?
Ja, glaub mir!
Heutzutage wissen die Käufer
sehr gut über den Markt Bescheid.
Sie kennen den Wert der Objekte,
und wenn sie
die Qualität des Objekts erkennen,
wird sie das zum Kommen motivieren.
Und sobald sie dann draussen mit all
den anderen Leuten Schlange stehen,
werden sie die Spannung spüren.
Sie werden sehen,
dass das Haus super schön ist,
und werden mehr bieten.
Ich hoffe nur,
dass die Leute wirklich kommen.
Ich sorge dafür,
dass sie euch die Bude einrennen.
Jetzt können wir uns verabschieden.
Okay, meine Lieben, macht's gut.
Ich war nicht ganz zufrieden
mit dem sales pitch.
Ich weiss nicht,
wie das auf Deutsch heisst.
Dass Hunderte Menschen die Strasse
entlang Schlange stehen werden,
das ist einfach nicht wahr.
Ich sehe es ja in der Nachbarschaft:
Wenn Häuser verkauft werden,
sind die Häuser offen und man sieht
ab und zu jemanden reingehen.
Aber so heiss ist der Markt nicht.
Architektur, Immobilien,
das heisst auch ganze Szenerien
und Träume zu verkaufen -
in bester Hollywood-Manier.
Roger ist in seine Träume versunken:
Seine Frau ist zurück aus den Ferien.
Wir sind offiziell zu spät dran.
Besser spät als nie.
Das kommt vor.
* Treibende, elektronische Musik *
Beim Friseur war ich auch nicht.
Eieiei!
Ohne Frauen läuft nichts.
Das sagen wir den Frauen.
We let them believe that.
The end of freedom.
Jetzt muss ich wieder gehorchen.
Jetzt muss ich wieder aufräumen.
Alles im Griff.
Blumen sind immer gut.
An alle Männer:
Hello.
- Hoi, Schatz.
Wie vom Duft der Rosen angezogen,
erscheint Susan, die Fee,
gefolgt von ihrem Neffen Severin.
Hast du für uns die Sonne bestellt?
- Bis 22 Uhr, dann kommt der Regen.
Vielen Dank für die Rosen, Schatz.
Ich fand, ich müsse ein Vorbild
für die Schweizer Männer sein.
Ich habe die Schweizer Grippe
mitgeschleppt.
Die kannst du gleich
aufs Dach binden.
Am letzten Tag
habe ich sie noch erwischt.
Fasnachtsgrippe nennt man das.
Hm, vielleicht.
Ich habe mich sehr gefreut,
zurückzukommen.
Ich habe ihn
fast einen Monat nicht mehr gesehen.
Ich habe die Schweiz zwar sehr
genossen, die Familie und Freunde,
und wir haben
viele Geburtstage gefeiert,
aber ich bin gerne
zu Roger zurückgekommen.
Denn mein Zuhause ist jetzt hier.
Mir gefällt es.
Aber ich gehe immer gerne
in die Schweiz, um Hallo zu sagen.
Etwa zwei- oder dreimal
pro Jahr gehe ich zurück,
um meine Freunde
und meine Familie zu sehen.
Ich mache hier drei Wochen Ferien
und werde Onkel Roger helfen.
Und shoppen mit der Tante.
- Genau.
Ein bisschen Geld ausgeben,
aber nicht wie letztes Mal.
Du warst schon mal hier.
- Das sind die Vorteile.
Ja.
Aber ich würde euch auch besuchen,
wenn ihr noch in Walenstadt wärt.
Aha!
- Das ist aber sweet.
* Einsame Westerngitarre *
Ich mache das jetzt, aber
normalerweise machen das die Kinder.
Sie werden wohl
beim Abräumen helfen,
jetzt sind sie zu sehr
in ihr Spiel vertieft.
Miloutchki!
Hast du Hunger? Ich mache mal Essen,
in 6-7 Min. ist es fertig.
Du wirst dein Spiel
unterbrechen müssen.
Tristan, hast du Hunger?
- Nein.
Ich werde jetzt kochen,
wir essen in 10 Min.
Am Mittwoch dürfen sie vor dem Essen
immer ein wenig gamen,
deshalb ist es super ruhig.
Und wie du siehst,
ist es sogar noch ruhiger,
wenn mein Mann Eddie nicht da ist.
Er gibt heute ein Konzert im
Zebulon, einem richtig coolen Club.
Er spielt dort die Songs
seines neuen Albums.
Wo hast du
das grosse Messer hingetan?
Du willst das grosse Messer?
Bon appetit!
Es schmeckt gut, nicht wahr?
Ja, gut.
Die Garage ist schrecklich.
Wir brauchen Hilfe.
Was musst du in der Garage machen?
Wir müssen wohl den Schrank
in die Garage stellen.
Schön sachte!
Braver Hund.
Sachte, Princess!
Wann kommt Papa nach Hause?
Ich weiss nicht genau,
wahrscheinlich nach Mitternacht.
Er eröffnet heute
für Gang Gang Dance im Zebulon.
Willst du mitkommen?
- Nein. Wir dürfen nicht.
Nein, du darfst ja nicht.
Du hast recht, es ist total doof,
aber ihr dürft nicht mitkommen.
Soll ich euch die Band zeigen?
* Energische Elektromusik *
Cool, nicht wahr?
- Ich find's gut.
Ich bin so glücklich, hier zu sein.
Ich vermisse die Schweiz
nicht wirklich.
Ich fühle mich hier freier, weil
ich nicht bei meinen Eltern wohne.
Ich kann essen gehen, wann ich will,
und ich richte mir die Tage so ein,
wie es mir gefällt.
In der Schweiz
war es auch umständlich,
weil ich in Lausanne wohne,
aber in Genf studiere.
Ich muss dauernd hin und her reisen.
Hier gehe ich
die ganze Zeit zu Fuss
oder ich nehme Uber
oder den Tretroller.
Ich habe viel mehr Freiheiten.
Ausserdem weiss ich nie,
was auf mich zukommt.
Was in einer Woche geschehen wird,
weiss ich nicht so genau.
Ich bin eine Verfechterin davon,
im Hier und Jetzt zu leben.
Es bringt nichts, zu viel
über die Vergangenheit nachzudenken
oder sich zu sehr
um die Zukunft zu sorgen.
Ich versuche so gut es geht,
einfach den Moment zu leben
und zu schätzen, was gerade ist.
Und mich nicht dauernd zu fragen,
ob ich die Schweiz vermisse.
* Einsame Westerngitarre *
In der Nacht sind alle Katzen grau.
Randy braucht ein paar Werkzeuge.
Ich trage keine Waffe, ich beschütze
meine Kunden mit meinem Körper.
Aber ich habe immer
dieses Pfefferspray dabei,
das man dem Angreifer
notfalls ins Gesicht sprüht.
Und ich verwende
diese Elektroschockpistole.
* Knattern *
Wenn man sie abfeuert und sie
die Haut des Angreifers berührt,
wird dieser kurz ohnmächtig.
Wenn man angegriffen wird,
muss man sie so abfeuern.
Aber das ist nur für den Notfall.
Ich musste sie persönlich
noch nie einsetzen,
aber ich trage diese Dinge
immer bei mir.
Sogar in der Nacht lässt der König
der Löwen seine Muskeln spielen.
Ich komme mindestens dreimal
pro Woche ins Fitnesscenter.
Schon als Jugendlicher habe ich
viel Zeit im Kraftraum verbracht,
weil ich in Form bleiben wollte.
Es hilft mir, aktiv zu bleiben und
mich auf die Arbeit vorzubereiten.
Mental fühle ich mich
wie ein 20-Jähriger.
Ich habe Angst vor dem Älterwerden,
nicht mehr alles machen zu können,
was ich möchte.
Und es gefällt mir nicht, mich
in gewissem Sinne alt zu fühlen.
Ich habe begriffen, dass ich es mit
54 ein bisschen ruhiger nehmen muss.
Das Atelier, die Kinder, dann gleich
weiter ans Konzert ihres Mannes.
Das Leben einer Künstlerin
steht nie still.
* Entspannte, perlende Musik *
In Los Angeles
kreuzen sich die Schicksale.
Jeder hat einen Lebenstraum,
jeder sucht einen Sinn.
Einige bleiben,
andere brechen wieder auf.
* Ruhige Gitarrenklänge *
Für Dora nimmt
der kalifornische Traum ein Ende
und der Schweizer Traum Form an.
Bis später.
See you later.
Ich bin nicht leichtfertig,
aber Beziehungen mit verschiedenen
Frauen - für mich stimmt das so.
Viel Erfolg!
Es war
keine ernstzunehmende Prüfung.
Mittendrin sagte der Prof:
"Aufgabe 6 ist unlösbar."
Hier sind die Korrekturen:
Bei Frage 1 BY gilt 5,25.
Nachdem ich 10 Min. vergeblich ver-
sucht hatte, die Aufgabe zu lösen.
(Alle) Dora, Dora, Dora!
* Jubel, Lachen *
Ich habe das Gefühl, ich bin
bei meiner eigenen Beerdigung.
* Fliessende Popmusik *